oh good see them did you notice our our
talent Booker was in his spring training
uniform for the oh my god that is
enraging that outfit that sets me
welcome and yeah what if you want to are
we live from your live right hi guys
we're talking about Stan Lee who we all
log on about Stan Lee yeah look at this
whole thing now with his mat he's been
like apparently been getting built out
of his money he's 95 and they said the
nurse was giving him happy ending
massages I'm like so bummed that that
has to end for them jimm leading that
true yes highlighted right and it says
for the court record there it is yeah
there Wow yesterday we were talking
about Stan Lee's money being taken from
him because that is confirmed even
Stan's people are saying that that like
this sounds catastrophic well it matters
some some of his money he just noticed
one point four million dollars is
missing and now Norton has gotten more
upset today than he was yesterday
because he's afraid that the happy
ending massages are also ending which to
Jim he's 95 years old I mean the guys
earned pleasure at the end of his life I
don't think that's unreasonable
respond
you might be fine I think it's like 5:30
in the morning my time is fly in talking
about this no I'm kidding no I know I
was last night yes I absolutely yeah
yeah and you're promoting sneaky pete
yeah season two
fitting you knew though that you knew
you guys knew you were getting a season
two before season 1 came out that was
all red eye yeah yeah I think I think
that that was always like right around
the time it was within maybe the same
week or was it one of those shows like
was it written with the full knowledge
that hopefully we'll get a season 2
because I feel like a lot of the shows
especially now on the streaming
platforms and things like that like the
first season's end up being self
contained because we don't know what's
gonna happen with this series after
season one yeah I mean I think
you don't really know from season to
season and I guess that's oh sorry that
speaks to you know even the potential of
season three we don't know yet right
and so I guess that's the dilemma and
and the I guess the shape of a show
whether what the showrunner ultimately
wants to do is to wrap it up and put a
nice bow on it or whatever but I think
that television has become a lot more
complex these days and and and and I
think audiences accept that so I think
it's it's different for every show yeah
how happy are you you you seem to be a
guy who likes a part too and you like to
know you're working you've got four
avatars 20 20 21 yeah 24 and 25 at least
it's gotta be nice to know you're not
getting killed off right yeah it is I
was just talking about that um that's
just something that I that I think we've
all been really looking forward to I
think that has a lot to do though not
just with the this the stories which I
which are incredible and unfathomable
and and and I read the scripts and I
can't even imagine how they could
accomplish you've read all five like
you've read the next four four all
written yeah Wow
but it's also just the group of people
that are involved and it's just not to
sound cocky but but it's just uh just
such a privilege are you guys gonna do
like are you gonna be filming parts of
the next one now or they'll it I'll beg
you just gonna do one film then another
film then another film no they gonna try
to shoot more than one film at one time
I don't know I know that that's a good
question didn't they do that with Lord
of the Rings I guess yeah
at the same time yeah cuz they were out
in like New Zealand and had to get
everybody out yeah
and that's practical and I think that
that's smart I think a lot of television
shows are doing that nowadays
as well I think that just economically
but I also I think just it's just
practical but I start 2019 so I really
get involved you start shooting 2019 for
the second one yeah and the technology
is getting so much better to like it
advances and it changes and it gets so
each film is going to be even more
impressive than the last one
technologically without a doubt yeah
there's a there's a lot of new
technology of course for these these
next films but it's interesting to think
because that I guess the well the first
avatar was was shot digitally which was
more or less at that time not not as
common as it is now and and you think
you know HD 1080 and now we have 4k but
I think the original avatar was actually
shot in in 720 oh wow wait and then they
uh president um and it still looks the
way it looks it's also like it's got to
be reassuring the James Cameron is
behind this stuff and if anybody has
been at the forefront of technology for
this stuff it's him right yeah I think
that's that's one of the things that
he's not he's obviously interested for
good interested in for a good reason and
he's always pushing that envelope and so
it truly is a learning experience every
time I how focus to see when he's on the
set like do you have moments where you
can grab him and just be like so what
was like one of the bottom of the ocean
like what like kids without a doubt yeah
there's so much stuff you want to talk
to a guy like that yeah he's so
informative and and so generous and and
again it really is nothing but a
learning experience for me and so yeah
I'm looking forward to it what do you
want to say to him can you not go to the
bottom of the ocean anymore
sanity what people with money do like
people who are that powerful like
Richard Branson had a friend who he was
killed like a single-engine he's an
adventurer these guys that are
adventurers yeah I don't have to be it's
like do you you've done the two big if
it's not and I think he's also I mean
that's really I think I've heard heard
so this is through somebody else say
that you know he really does the films
so that he can go do that at the condo
sorry yeah and he's even said that he's
interested in what goes down and what
goes up you know so I think at one point
he was on the board of directors for
NASA as well he just has that that
extraordinary mind maybe that's what
helps him make good movies the fact that
he does think that way and he's just not
so obsessed with enjoying the money but
he wants to go out and like really do
real-life things but I just can't
comprehend having that kind of money and
power and why did you go to the bottom
of the ocean it's it makes me know and
it's probably healthier because I bet
like if your passion is filmmaking and
then you go to like James Cameron levels
and you're there already like you didn't
have you get excited right exactly like
when you when you accomplish the thing
you were looking to accomplish and it's
over like people have that struggle
sometimes when what you want to
accomplish is discovering what's at the
bottom of the ocean that seems like yeah
but I also know that he's absolutely I
mean he's a storyteller and and and he
loves filming I mean I think you know I
would assume and he it always is it
really is another adventure for him it's
it's making a film is it's not it's a
different experience with him than it is
just the run on the mill sort of go to
work and clock in and and show up just
set and and and let's do the shot list
and this and that do you have any of
that in you any of that like adventure
stuff or do you like doing any of that
stuff or dude I mean I definitely like I
definitely want to make my own movies
and and and and and I think that I grew
up in the industry and so so I've more
or less explored things and had the
opportunity to you know to travel and
and again you know explore various
aspects of life really through that so
you know going to Africa or New Zealand
for Avatar being exposed to that
technology and all that um and so I
think that that's been my my focus is is
filmmaking why New Zealand do they shoot
like why do these is it better location
or tax breaks or is it just for the the
out the outdoor shots you can get wool
there's an amine well there's an
incredible infrastructure there because
of Peter Jackson's studio and Wetty the
the the the visual effects company down
there and I know that I think Jim has a
has purchased and property down okay
and so so so I think he lives there part
of the time I'm not sure but um but yeah
I never actually really bothered to ask
that question I wandered but then but
yeah it's great yeah when you're so
happy to be so exact the worst thing you
want to do it's it's a pretty big place
is it watch it be a huge place honestly
one of the the greatest countries I've
ever had the opportunity to visit I
really mean that and and we lived in
Wellington we were there for five months
and it really is I mean it's just it's
just like the ideal I mean political
ease socioeconomically everything about
it for me is is sort of yeah it's
incredible I think we all could learn
from the from the folks down there did
you come back at all not five months or
did you stay there
yeah it's straddled Christmas so I came
back during that time are you looking at
five months for each of these next four
films or more or less maybe um I don't
know I
know how much I'm so it is it is it a a
tough choice for you when something like
this comes up like you would think it's
a no-brainer because avatar is James
Cameron's it's amazing franchise but
you're also saying for at least two
years if not a lot more yeah I'm this is
what I'm doing you know what I mean yeah
that was a big thing I mean also because
of the show and right and you look at a
commitment like that is you're saying
the last one is 2024 and then also but
the you know potentially going into you
know maybe we'll see how it turns out
but you know several more years of
sneaky P you start to go that's gonna be
basically the entirety of my 40s and and
you start to look at look at things like
that but sign up for that I can tell you
what my forties consisted of gives you
pause do you do think about these things
and you know again a big focus for me is
is being on is making my own films and
and maybe having the opportunity to to
tell my own stories in that way which
again I mean you know you've got work
kind of guaranteed now so it's one of
those things just like Cameron it's like
well I got to make these films and
that's gonna fund this maybe once you're
done with all this you're gonna be like
okay now I can go and feel financially
free enough to take some risks make some
films do that type of thing yeah exactly
what's it like working with with ethan
embry now because i just get such a kick
out of the fact that you two guys are on
the show because you know you two guys
came up together and yeah we've known
each other since we were teenagers he's
I think both members of the wonders at
one point yeah exactly the the onio
netters yeah the I think we we get it's
myself ethan embry and i guess that the
lead singer of Green Day we all get
confused
but no Ethan is an extraordinary talent
he is so good in this season of sneaky
pete and and he has a lot he plays well
he plays the real Pete but we also have
jane addams who came on who's also just
it was incredible and the two of them
together it's it's it's I think it's
worth watching the season alone for that
so ethan embry did all these like movies
and he was a big when he's a teenager
he's like a big actor at that time I was
in a tungsten Empire Records he's in
that thing you do he's in all these
movies and I think I didn't know what he
was doing for a while and before Sneaky
Pete came out he was in this movie I'm
blanking on the title of it but though
it was like this great movie where the
premise was that this guy with all this
money David Cho catchy you know he means
these two guys in a bar and just
convinces them to do crazy [ __ ] for
money
the former Duke Chronicles wasn't the
Marvin oh no it was a different one but
he's paying them to do like I'll give
you 50 bucks if you punch someone in the
face and you just watch it escalate and
escalate and escalate yeah but you know
staying alive it was he wasn't alive no
it was on golden boy but I like ethan
embry I was like all of a sudden he's
like this big badass dude and I was like
look at this isn't oh yeah he went to
the gym yeah but he's perfect for sneaky
pete yeah kind of amazing
yeah he is yeah definitely I always ask
I what was the first thing you
auditioned for and got the first thing I
owned that yeah I was
I just turned 10 years old and it was a
um it was well at the time the company
was changing over from Union 76 to
unocal 76 and now I think they're just
76 but it was a it was a commercial the
gas company yes yes it was a it was a
yes so it was and I think the commercial
was about that changeover so it was I
yeah ten years old and you and you were
in the commercial yes but fight that age
though do you appreciate that you
understand how show business is a
crapshoot it's really difficult maybe
that is you don't even appreciate how
amazing is that you land something when
you audition for it yeah I guess so I
mean um I don't know yeah you're ten
years old and and I know that I mean I
just as I could say that you know
looking at this generation and and and
trying to comprehend the sort of
zeitgeist or the psychology of that
north sociology of that I for me I grew
up during the blockbuster era and and
and and there's a part of me that that
even just being involved in acting that
wonders how I could have avoided it
being you know growing up in Los Angeles
and and my family we were all such film
buffs and so that was part of it I think
you know I mean it was in Los Angeles
you you grow up
Wow cameras everywhere
the I was I was saying that gosh I lost
my you growing up in the blockbuster era
yeah in Los Angeles yeah and I guess you
know the I mean three doors down on the
block that I grew up there was another
kid who got an agent and it was just
kind of it almost it honestly it feels
you pick we Astaire what does that mean
he doesn't know I know it's just
everywhere the industry at least but you
should oppose to have an age 18:32
when I was growing up just kidding and
and so and so yeah I guess it's it was
that I I think I just it was something
that I knew and and there was a moment
where I also the formative years and the
my big influence that it was you know in
the early 90s with you know you have
Martin Scorsese
in doing Cape Fear which is one of my
all-time favorite films
Gary Oldman
Daniel day-lewis and and the method
acting this is sort of like the second
coming of or or third coming of that of
that group of people so it was all about
commitment and trying to do something
and push yourself and seeing how far you
could go with how great was it when Max
Cady gets on the boat and she splashes a
kettle of steaming water this face
incredible for me something hot guy that
monsters shot at such a incredible films
right Jessica Lange the Wahine in the in
the theater at school Julia Louis we all
love that none of us want to admit like
we know she was younger but that is one
of the best scenes ever when he's
hanging upside down on the phone yeah
camera rotates it was great yeah good
choice
unless he did that though Scorsese yeah
that's the thing about like it kind of
gets lost when you start talking about
all the like the great Scorsese movies
like for some reason people forget to
mention Cape Fear and I don't know they
should because I can see now when
Goodfellas and Raging Bull one of the
things we just you know to mention Cape
Fear should you do you get into that
like do you end up falling into
character when you're on set and just
kind of staying there or do you when the
cameras on I don't know I I mean I guess
so I think it's almost as a pejorative
connotation this the notion of method
acting because I think that a lot of
people misconstrued that for just being
a complicated [ __ ] on the set and and
no I think that it really is just simply
if you were to just distill it down to
its it's just about it's in relative
terms really it's oh it's just about
really just trying to commit yourself to
what you're doing so you are a method
actor no I mean I don't you in character
and said all the time that's where
that's where I am it's the school
I went to yes and and really what I want
to know is when you did Ted were you
that because what if amazing character
and yeah everything every project is
different and and and and it's it's I
think you you have to you know as much
as you have a foundation for your
approach just something that I you
always have to adapt do you get what
will they call you will they call you
your name or they call you your
character name
oh no that call me my name cuz there are
guys that only want to be called like I
think Danny Lewis Lee did Lincoln wanted
to be called labor like he slept in the
same kind of belly he's one of those
guys he's weird they made it he made him
call him Honest Abe hey Honest Abe
proportion oftentimes you'll hear all
these rumors and there's just a lot of
that stuff is ridiculous or or just just
adding the like yeah I can act again I
mean it's like he said they saying he
stepped away or this was yeah I don't
know I mean he's just so incredible who
knows you know I think they've been
actors before that have retired and
think and then they come back and you
wonder is that sometimes you know to get
a movie going yes my last one you know
bands will do that with tours sure I'm
serious last chance then you go out in
there back next year last yeah you get
well you get a script like boiler room
which is like one of my favorite movies
ever and and you realize like you're
looking through this script you're like
I'm pretty much like every shot of this
film is me like this is this film
follows me does that become like this is
amazing I'm gonna get to flex my muscle
how many or is it an intimidating thing
like I got to put this thing on my
shoulders yeah I don't know it's it's
never been a status thing for me or
something that I look at as an
opportunity I think it really is just
looking at the challenge of trying to
trying to make something good or be
honest with it or try to you know I
guess the focus is to just understand
the experience of the character in the
story and I think that that's that's I
think the the main focus yeah when you
would you
end up like when you get a script like
that or when you find out you're doing
it you start to research the world and
get into like the penny stock companies
and the OS and the guys who end up
taking the fast money and everything
yeah as much as you can it depends on
how much time you have
yeah you know I mean I think that if you
you're you're it's rare but it's really
fortunate when you have three or four
months that you know you're going to be
working on something to be able to
explore that universe and and it it's
just so fascinating it can be but
oftentimes it'll be two weeks or
whatever rounds so were you a hip hop
fan before that movie or because there's
like it's not so much a hip hop but
there's so much influence yeah it was in
the the soundtrack for that movie is and
very orange yeah yeah I don't know I you
know I um my taste is a it's it's
changed over the years and and I'm
definitely I love hip-hop but also just
now I think if you were to ask me what
favorite music is it's it's Bruckner
seventh really you know I mean I'm
really trying to get into classical
music and that's do you pop like an
[ __ ] yeah I I used to I used to pop
lock I'm not gonna lie about
photographer over there kind of looks
like she's ready to pop lock please I'm
a master really she likes to pop when he
gets a good joke I can't do it now
though I've heard every muscle in my
body I would love to do it the one that
makes you funny Yamato co-host
ha